another aircraft of some sort Airship
balloon something was shot down today
who owns it what were the circumstances
was the president directly involved in
ordering this uh and is wreckage being
recovered
Kate so I'm going to try remind me if I
forget something yes the president
absolutely was involved in this decision
he ordered it at their recommendation of
Pentagon leaders he wanted it taken down
and they did that they did it using
fighter aircraft to sign the U.S
Northern command the Pentagon will have
more to say about the details of this
later on this afternoon it's only just
within the last hour
uh we're calling this an object because
that's the best description we have
right now we do not know who owns it uh
whether it's a whether it's state-owned
or or corporate owned or privately owned
we just don't know uh we don't we don't
know so I said state-owned we don't know
if it's state-owned
um and we don't uh understand the full
purpose we don't have any
we don't have any information that would
confirm a stated purpose for this object
we do expect to be able to recover uh
the debris since it fell not only within
our territorial space but on what we've
been what we and I believe is is Frozen
uh water so
a recovery effort will be made
um and uh we're hopeful that it'll be
successful and then we can learn a
little bit more about it so parents like
the Chinese aircraft no it was it was
much much smaller than the Spy balloon
that we took down last Saturday
um the way it was described to me was
roughly the size of a small car as
opposed to
a payload that was like two or three
buses size right so much much smaller
um uh and um and there and not of the
same not
uh no um no significant payload if you
will
Leslie is is it now the policy of the
United States that if unidentified
aircraft are over U.S territory that it
is likely the president will choose to
shoot it down the president will always
act in the best interest of our national
security and in the Safety and Security
of the American people